you are looking at the gravestone of
arguably the greatest gladiator who ever
lived interestingly seeing that recent
Studies have suggested Gladiators were
mostly vegetarians he may also have been
the toughest vegetarian of all time
living for the fight flammer fought as a
Secor which means he wore a big metal
helmet wielded a Roman Gladius a
legendary Roman shortsword against the
raras an incredibly agile highly skilled
opponent opponent armed with a trident
and a net the raras meaning net man was
styled after a fisherman using his
weighted net and Trident he would trap
his opponents and skewer them alive
alternatively he would use his net to
entangle his opponent's weapon but
flammer as a secutor meaning pursuer
would hunt his opponent down like a
sword wielding Mike Tyson and dodging
his net in the Long Reach of his Trident
rip him to pieces with his Gladius